KIDS IN THE BAHAMAS AND A LUXUR
PENTHOUSE, BUT DON'T ASK
QUESTIONS.
HE HAS BEEN AROUND A LOT OF PAI
FINE FINANCIERS AND AN
INTERESTING PERSON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THEY ARE BASICALLY THREATENING
ELON MUSK FORM OF PODIUM ON THE
WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE HE BRINGS
BACK FREE SPEECH BY IGNORING
THIS.
>> THIS ARRANGED MARRIAGE
BETWEEN BIG GOVERNMENT IN BIG
BUSINESS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHERE WERE ELON WAS A DARLING
WHEN HE WAS HE FELL OUT OF FAVO
WHEN HE STARTED PUSHING FREE
SPEECH.
TAKE THIS GUY WHO ACTUALLY GOES
BY SPF IN THE CRYPTO WORLD, SO
LET'S CALL HIM SPF, THE
INTERESTING THING HERE IS HE
BOUGHT PROTECTION HE PLAYED THE
OLD GOLDMAN SACHS PRE- 2008 GAME
.
GOLDMAN SACHS PAID FOR A LOT OF
PROTECTION FROM THE GOVERNMENT
TO PAY OUT, IT'S LIKE AN
INSURANCE POLICY WHEN IT MATTER
MOST WHEN THE 2008 FINANCIAL
CRISIS HIT, THAT'S WHY GOLDMAN
SACHS BOUGHT BUILT OUT WHILE
EVEN BROTHERS DIDN'T TEASE ATOP
DONOR OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
EVEN AS HIS EXCHANGE WAS GOING
BUST, YET THERE IS ONE SMALL
WANTS TO THIS, I THINK THEY
MIGHT ACTUALLY GO AFTER HIM AND
PUNISHING ANYWAY.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE KNOW, HE HA
PLEDGED UP TO $1 BILLION IN
DONATIONS THIS CYCLE AND NEXT S
THERE ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
UPSET THAT HE ONLY GAVE 30 OR
40 MILLION.
IF THEY WENT AFTER HIM IT'S
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T BUY THE
GOLDPLATED INSURANCE POLICY HE
STOPPED AT THE CHEAP VERSION
INSTEAD.
IF HE IS INDICTED OR IF HE DOES
GET IN TROUBLE, THAT WILL BE ON
OF THE LESSONS OF THE STORY IS
PAY FOR FREIGHT OR YOU WILL GET
IN TROUBLE.
>> INTENDS SECONDS, AND OLIGARC
PLEDGING TO THROW A BILLION
DOLLARS INTO DEMOCRATIC ELECTION
.
DEMOCRATS USED TO COMPLAIN ABOU
BIG MONEY, DIDN'T THEY?
TO KEEP WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
CITIZENS UNITED CORPORATIONS AR
NOT PEOPLE, THE PARTY USED TO B
SKEPTICAL OF THE EXPANSION OF
CORPORATE POWER.
NOW WE ARE THE ONES THAT WANT
THOSE CORPORATIONS AND AUTOCRAT
TO ACT MORE LIKE PEOPLE.
IT IS A BIT OF AN IRONY.
IT'S AN ABOUT-FACE OVER THE LAS
TEN YEARS.
WHAT THEY REALIZED IT'S IT'S NO
IN ARRANGED MARRIAGE, IT'S MORE
JUST LIKE MUTUAL PROSTITUTION
AND IT WORKS AS LONG AS EACH
SIDE GET SOMETHING OUT OF THE
TRADE.
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET TO WHERE